hello everyone thanks for coming to this
talk I'm pretty amazed about how many of
you have come so thanks for coming
I've been doing video games for more
than 20 years almost about the same time
professionally but before then since I
was like a teen I always have a deep
passion for open source I started using
linux desktops for for like seems like
94 or 95 it's been a long time so when I
started working professionally in game
development most most week on most of
the game development Institute industry
uses Windows which was always a problem
for me because I don't didn't want to go
to it to use it in fact if you consider
like the total revenue of the software
industry about 25 percent is the video
game industry of all the total software
industry and for doing something so be
open-source hasn't like penetrated so
much in the in the game industry as much
as it is in enterprise and all the kind
of industries so oh you always wanted to
develop games with the open source are
you actually deal in the past so after
many years different things that happen
I ended up being one of the original
engine you probably have heard of it at
this point together with the real Mansu
I know I'm sure if he's Aaron but he
also came to the FOSDEM like four years
ago
ok I need more probably five now and
he's been growing a lot but so about
this talk the talk is creating the next
kid game with free and open source
software tools the idea is to show that
it can be made and I will talk a bit
about how the process was for creating
or new third-person shooter demo which
you probably already saw in your booth
so let's get started what's the
motivation go log 3 was released exactly
a year ago it we need a demo to showcase
all the new rendering features before
that Gilad was mostly a mobile engine to
make mobile games but for version 3 we
rewrote it mostly rendering so we can
make something realize
you can see those three shots are or new
renderer that came out a year ago but we
don't have anything to showcase it so
even if it was pretty good
you couldn't show that what it would
actually do so we did a new demo to
showcase it our plan but we have this
other or simple 2d and 3d platformer
demos is a game engine where you can do
separately to the N 3d they are like
separate engines in one they work mostly
the same but 3d and to the api's so we
have this platform demo which is almost
the same : to the MPD so you can just be
great from 2d to 3d which is something
many developers to at some point of
their career but the thing is a lot of
3d platformer the more you look very
nice in the arts of this one I made the
art for this the 3d one the original one
was made by an artist called Fernando
Fernando Calabro and I tried to
replicate his style in 3d but I am a 3d
a terrible 3d artist so it looked really
bad but I know that Godfrey was capable
of much better so this is where the
journey begins with donation money we
have a patron if you're not one of our
sponsors please become more open source
we use some of the nation's to to hire
an artist we actually hire the same guy
that made the pixel art because he's
actually a really cool 3d artist
actually he's a professional 3d artist
and this was done as a hobby so we hired
the same guy to make this demon we
started with concept and prototyping I
worked so long in the game industry I'm
very used to this if you do a really
good concept and prototype and usually
properly you can get really really high
quality later on you you will ensure
that all the problems or solve it by
this face and not later so well this we
started planning it the idea was that it
should look very nice it should be like
futuristic design because it's very
trendy to make futuristic style in
Sweden most artists want to do least
nowadays like 10 years ago it was like
mediaeval and now it's futuristic
we want you to make it cool because
something that looks very amateur when
3d is when you make like four square
levels
or lucky so we make wanted to make
something really pretty which is like
cool which is way more
professional-looking
we want to have multiple rooms and it
had to be shared with pretty so this is
what kind of the idea it's kind of
around level you go around the deck and
then you get to the Richter room you
will see soon so first we started with
level blocking the artist made the level
blocking in blender
he just took all the ideas and he made a
really basic geometry I'm not sure if
you can see because contrast it was very
good but he means all I'm looking my
friend like everything that was going to
me in the level he made a mesh for it
but really simple just no textures very
flat no detail
nothing the idea was to test the game
flow destinations of the level and also
test the lighting how was the general
idea was going to be softer wars we
character prototyping if there is
something you learned in the game
industry is when you come when you
profit the pipe when you prototype sorry
you can't make like the art cannot be
find out you can't even put cubes
somewhere or maybe more detailed
geometry for your characters for
everything but the animation has to be
like near final or final because part of
your gameplay is the animation always in
a game or most types of game if you're
going to do something the animations
have to be near final just using
placeholder animation is asking for
trouble because animation is part of the
core mechanic almost always in a game if
it's 3d pretty much always so animation
was one of the first things we do these
are like a test model it looks really
complicated what is not the final one
you can see this was an Inlander we did
the model and animated them in blender
this was done in 4x4 number so yeah I
never do animation placeholders if you
make a prototype just from the very
beginning try to make sure the animation
is final when you prototype or make free
games especially so later we try to look
Emporium prototyping we didn't have a
level Oh for some reason the video is
not looking very good but sorry we
didn't really have a level yet it wasn't
model so we started doing prototyping in
this very like black and white scene
usually when you do prototyping and be
the range
to use these squares which I think are
like two meters by 2 meters so you have
a better idea of distances this is just
practices which are typical in the game
industry interaction and control must
feel like final from a prototype you'll
rarely try to make something that you
will improve later it doesn't look final
in the prototype you're doing it wrong
so this is the animation tree got three
has actually this is go to the point one
which is coming soon Hasaan animation 3
which means you can create all the
animation interactions like state
machines and changing States blending
space this is very common in boring game
engines it allows the animator to test
all the interactions or all the
transitions around the blendings
manually from an UI and then the
programmer can take this tree and use it
from the code like changing state from
walking to jumping into anything so
animation trees are a very programmer
friendly to like communicate between the
animator and the programmer and make
sure everything works as intended we use
real motion with motion is a technique
word animator animate with actual motion
right for example original in games you
would like animate a walk cycle but it
was in place so when you put it in a
game in the football slide that was very
common I think as a squid first game
that actually did remotion properly so
we use route motion which means that you
can see in the video sorry it's a bit
broken but when you change States
it changes animation on the blending and
you can see that the animation is like
it's totally synchronized to the foot of
the character if you saw that the
previous life is one you can see the
animator actually moves with with the
object is not in place so when in the
engine will remove this front this
translation this transform um you use
even code this transform is retry from
code and used to actually move with the
logic so we effects the effects is
something that I actually also needs to
be pretty finely in a proper prototype
may not be exactly this final final
version but it has to be very close to
final because again both the effects and
animation are parts of our interaction
and that is actually part of a core
mechanics so be affects how do we find
out from the prototype god is very cool
it has something that no engines has
which is an animation system where you
can pretty much animate absolutely
anything in the engine you can't even
change the mass or change a tube first
called functions you can do so much from
the animation system and a lot that you
can like do a v8 VFX very nicely so this
is a combination of particles and
physics and and shaders that change
parameters all controlled by an
animation like this this shooting effect
is is done from there you can see a
battle here in how the battle looks
sorry again for there for this so this
is an interaction you can see that this
explodes and then the states are trying
to rigidbody so they just blow up on and
the fire starts emitting this is
absolutely all done from animation
there's no bowling ball so all texturing
before modeling usually want to do
texturing so you cannot get off an idea
of how to do it I will explain I mean
the the texture water flow there are two
textual workflows you can use it's
important to understand how to create
textures if you're going to make a game
understand where they can come from how
you can use them and different things by
the way I'm giving the new in 2.10 is
fantastic it's really really good I will
show you a bit later why and then you
can find base textures somehow there are
many royalty-free textures around you
can find on the Internet people just
like taking pictures of things just to
make textures you can create them from
photos this is why I will explain later
there is I wish there was like a
substance painter alternative or Sobel
source there is yet so we're waiting on
blender to do it
hello if anyone from the underneath here
please hurry up after 2.8 is out you can
also be painted with Prieta many types
of game used like unpainted textures if
you remember remember games I wouldn't
waker they have very pretty paint
hand-painted stills tiled textures I
wanted to like go more in depth on that
Wharf Raimondo in hindsight textures in
Krita but the presentation was really
long and you really need artistic skill
to do it so I will probably skip it on
one day extend on that I will
how to make a texture from a photo you
can do this both I think in when
Twitter is probably a mother's
sweeted for photo manipulation here's an
example I took this picture myself at I
was at a Roman Roman ruins while
visiting Europe so I took this picture
of I think this floor is from pretty old
I took a picture I thought this was
going to be a nice texture at some day
this was like 10 years old but I will
use it to show you how you can make it
in a new texture so you first have to
look for a wretched that some tile
usually most textures how our region
that could be nice for tiling in this
example this one is kind of obvious
where it can tile of course when you
well if it's not totally aligned to to
our to our region - after our protector
you can use key to transform or
perspective transform to align me to a
box then you can crop it this is
something pretty useful if I'm doing
you can use a layer offsets by hud
so this is pretty much the texture was
moved to the right and hot down and then
just moved around like like tiled you
can explore how well it tiles so you can
see it doesn't really tile
well because of two reasons first it
just doesn't match from one side to the
other and the second reason is that it
has a gradient you can see when we turn
it here in 3d there is a there is like a
gradient
it makes the title pretty bad so to get
rid of the gradient you can use
high-pass filter this was added to give
2.10 you use a high-pass filter effect
and then it removes bike frequencies all
ridings go away and just gives like
pretty flat you can see here if you look
in detail at the center cross it's not
like matching still very well but it's
much better for tiling because it's just
like never aliens are gone so to fix the
tiling program you just use the the
clone tool on it and just fix it pretty
much that's an easy way to do it the
most common one well as I say here just
you just use the clone tool there is
another technique I will show in a bit
which is pretty cool for fixing tiling
so then you kind of just like brightness
and
raishin contrast and hue and everything
and make it pretty as you want you can
see here that is styling really well
this has perspective in the model and
it's selling very well so low contrast
usually hootsburgh try to make your
textures like more color focused and
contrast focus that we usually look
better in the game I explained here how
to create normal maps I would need a bit
quick usually if you want to make normal
maps you have to start from let's call a
hang map you can see there in the in the
middle this is a hate map it shows like
what is why it is about and what this
block is low so once you have a height
map you can use the normal map effecting
game I'm not sure if it come with it or
it's an extension there are other
applications you can load they just take
a shape and return a normal map so this
way you can use it it shows like it has
depth when you're working on it
some methods may break the tiling you
can fix it again with what you have just
learned embossing may work for creating
like a hike map you can see on top the
embossing of the original texture you
can use it to create a height map kind
of like here's a really simple magic
trick I love for tiling textures you can
see original texture you can see it all
right that's with me tile very well
neither vertical nor horizontally it's a
nice textured Asim tile so what you do
is I just like this is the base layer I
duplicate it and another layer above
has an effect it has a filter which
which is cool make seamless but all it
does is create a like a crossfade of the
texture it really looks pretty bad but
it makes it seamless but it looks pretty
bad so what I do is just this above
layer I make it like child seamless with
that effect but then I just use the
eraser and erase everything but not the
border I just leave the border and then
I merge it down to the layer below and
you can see on the right it looks
fantastic.this this is in my opinion the
best way to tell textures it's like
effortless it could be done with a
script if you want I go to matically it
looks really well so this is just a
small technique you can use if you can
check back on the presentation like your
online and this really goes for typing
textures so then we're going to modeling
this is not something i use for the demo
this technique but i
I would like to strain it it's a very
common technique in the in the industry
you just make an atlas with shapes that
may be like related to the way you are
going to model a level or something here
you can see put like two plants of food
something with a detail and then
something round and then something that
looks like a wall paper or something you
can paint the head map I painted this
caper myself with and then from the
head map you can get the normal map
there then I converted this one to an
occlusion and then you can use the rest
for like metal Ness and wrongness which
is common PVR workflows I'm not going to
scream River you can find a little bit
so once you have those textures with
your atlas with kind of shapes random
shapes you put on it just make objects
that use those random shapes just be
creative like you make those shoes first
and then you try to think and how to
make objects that use them so they made
some furniture like you have window at a
chair another table and then you can use
it and it's really quick you can model
really quickly with Dobby just just just
make the models and you lean up based on
the on the model on the texture it's a
very quick you need to kind of use the
same color for everything because when
you use 3d and you use meat maps they
will bleed a bit so if you kind of use
the same color it is not really
noticeable the big thing about this
technically you can create content a lot
in works really good like for futuristic
things like I think I read the document
I think overwatch uses this technique
for many of the levels so that that can
be of interest so this is an example I
made this and render eating a lot I made
all this furniture and the walls and
this took me like three hours or
something like that is really really
quick you just use this technique from
scratch and you can make like a level
really quickly so this is geometry based
modeling which is actually what we use
for the the demo that this new
third-person shooter them of for Godot
this is a really nice technique it's a
very modern technique because you can
only do it like know what is the GPUs
are super fast and amount of practices
in the model doesn't really matter that
much so what you do is just model all
your return in geometry just forget
about painting a detail in the texture
it may be very subtle if you enter in
the texture but most of your tile like
90% of it is just geometry you have like
a hole in the middle of the Finch's
model hole you have like a small just
beam or something you just mobile it
just everything goes to the texture
model every every detail forget about
like using the the detectors to paint
the detail just go crazy it's okay then
the new GPUs don't really care about so
much polygons know what is little for
the new GPUs so then what you can do is
used to our mapping triple our mapping
is colossal Alto texturing it's a way
that just just like blends between
factories we access the textural piles
in every axis and blends depending on
the direction the faces is having this
is color to texture in England you have
like this technique you can use so then
I think is that you can just set up a
lot of materials and then you just
assign them randomly where you have like
the metal material the tooth material
the school material and then just put
them there I know that for example many
companies in the Indiana mission
industry like doing Wars is this
technique these have somebody that that
goes everything and then someone else
makes a materials and a Simpson or
instance to the object so this is a
really nice technique and you can get
really nice results like this is a
picture it's using mostly this then it
has a bit of texture painting but mostly
you can see its own geometry you can
make it look really nice here you can
see that a few more examples it's very
nice I mean you just kind of like you
just go crazy with the geometry doesn't
matter it will look cool and then you
just assign the materials for for
everything so level design I will show
it if I have time in blender
still have a bit of time so when I'm
done with the presentation I will show a
bit the projects live so then artists
converts all the flogging the blocking
that was done initially it's converted
to final assets they are given more
detail and the earth texture this is
blender dailies
our discuss school freedom the level is
actually made in blender many people
think that is better or usually bird
with just model different pieces and
assemble them in the game engine usually
won't work professionally this is kind
of finesse it was the in designer
doesn't really know how to like put
together level with pieces so it's very
we just agree on what the level is and
then the artist can go wild and do all
their art and all the detail and
everything that just conforms to that to
what originally was a grid with the
designer so the propeller is much easier
this way in my opinion collisions are
other manually also in the in here like
for example we have a something in
Goodall you just add like - call - the
name of the object when imported to the
engine a collision will be generated for
it so converse with physic shapes you
can do just - call so the collision has
the same the same shape as the object
you model but sometimes you make a model
really complicated on physics and just
like our beam is low when you have so
many triangles on the collision so it's
very common to just make a new version
of the model that is only like the
vertices in the faces just for collision
so you make it an Inlander you you add
like - call-only which is means this is
just for collision no no art when
imported the art is the little so here's
an example of how it works
this is like the base model which is
bottle and the collision is another
object I put it to wireframe so it's
easier to see like which one is the
collision which is the what is the
object using all these very complex
geometry and the physics engine is going
to kill the physics engine so you need
to make something simpler under the
englander you just make the basement
area since blender doesn't really
support some kind of well it does it
will now in it's easier to just make
something very simple in the reference
for the materials when imported to the
game engine
you said the actual materials and finish
with the textures and everything and you
always use very verbose name so when go
into the game engine you find the
materials or wise if you have like
blender material dot zero zero one
you're not going to find it
this thing was for lights you just can
put like lights everywhere when import
you to the engine the light will be in
the engine
I would keep this you can use like one
thing to notice that is important is
that most 3d application usually in the
industry everyone uses the FBX format
for export in 3d we can't use this
single dot because this has a very very
interesting restricting license it's not
compatible with open-source so the
earlier performance we can use our dye
which is colera which is all until the
f2 which is newer both were really well
for exporting to game engines so nurse
now one a fourth for reverse engineering
the FBX format it's like a very closed
format there's no specification just as
close to library to open it but it's
being reverse-engineer so I hope we can
still support it soon because people
really requesting the ones that use my
arrow similar so this is the last part
engine integration so it's everything
making everything pretty in ecology just
export to the project and it will open
it I will show with this later very on
the running on the engine so the ideas I
will explain quickly you just import
this then you just the materials you
just put all the textures this is just
plot here the materials were added but
there's no no lighting finally we are
mister like modifying the lights and
everything in ecology you have some call
instances like the scene that was
important you can't touch it because it
content is like the cholera or the gltf
file so what we do is just instantiate
that scene into another one which is
very common in Inga lot
you said the travel and you can make
local changes in the new one this way
you can edit your original the original
scene that was exported from 3d without
like changing it why is this important
because this is my goal and I keep
changing the scene in blender and then
we will react sport it and if you made
local changes directly on that Sun in
the engine they will be lost
so in god you instantiate the same from
the artist and make local changes in the
instance so the artist will just save
the scene again and we imported
automatically and all that all the
changes are kept well finally the same
the lighting you can just add like
lights and shadows and everything then
you have the final step which is like
Laure elimination which is the like
bounces usually you set up the direct
lights we said that likes this writer
writing which means that this is just
where the light effects the only new
nation is what that's the bounce like if
I like throw a very very strong light to
the floor it will bounce and spread
across all the room so global
illumination is pretty much that you can
see it has something called a pro we
said use urban area and all lighting
inside it will just bounce around
it looks pretty pretty you can see the
compression above and below and then
what you cannot like pretty effects like
ambient occlusion screen space
reflection on depth of field blue or you
cannot fog anti-aliasing bloom and
everything so in the end it ended up
looking like this you can see it looks
pretty nice I mean it's like kind of
what games know what eyes look like I
saw the detail and it is very nice this
see we have still a bit more I will show
you this working and running on the
engine I will show you for the demo if
we never seen it before
[Music]
how it finished with the second okay
this follows the planning you can just
walk around the stage
you consider the the character moves
around and all the lighting from the
environment effects it this is the real
time if I get close to this you consider
this emission of material is affecting
the character there's the enemy
so yeah that's how we we are engine
turned up looking so
[Applause]
Thanks I will show you a bit how it is
done in the engine so you can see a bit
more detail about the process I will
open the player sin this is the player
you can see here this is something that
God does or it says sin root you can see
here that this is actually a COLLADA
file which was exported directly from
from blender this was associated in this
current scene which is the players in
the players in like has a node a base
node which is like a kinematic body
which allows for moving with with
physics and everything it has a lot of
animations and everything you you may
expect this is everything imported from
blender all the animations in blender
this is an emission-free
like for example you can see that there
is a blend filter and like the ice or a
similar animation that's running in
parallel that makes it ring no matter
what is going on this is a cool
animation tree you can for example or if
this this is solid for this is a blend
alt for aiming up and down a blend novel
for example this one shot no you can
turn on and it's going to just jump
doesn't do much interesting now I know
actually that for landing not jumping
this is mostly machine you can change
like the animations when we will
probably notice that when you put walk
the guys like totally standing this is
because there is a blend spacing here so
depending on where the blend Spaceballs
actually need to activate the animation
see this is walking with gun walking
with a gun I can change the blending and
in this axis is switching between done
right no gun and this is just the
animation speed if I change this like
you can see it just changes the
animation speed they were occurring or
where I am I can just start walking then
I shoot when I should it's it's just
like takes out the weapon
there's a back way now there's a lot of
interesting things you can doing with an
emission-free so let me show you the
scene this pretty big will take just me
okay this is the actual level see
imported from dunder you can see this
huge green thing is the GI probe this is
what gives like all the light bounces
you can set it up around anything I mean
we'll give like once this is really good
to set up here you can see just
everything like the lights on the
enemies and everything you can see that
this is what I mentioned this is
actually the same as imported from from
from blender it's like instantiated here
it's great because it's like children
knows you can still modify any other
properties so when you imprint or the
original file it they will they keep the
changes this is the enemy scenes here's
the enemies you have different like
robots you have like areas for the sound
you can for example here you can see we
have a mixer so mix earning a lot this
means that I can for example like set up
an area around where this is I can give
it any shape and they say that any area
and it sound that place on any area is
going to like the bus which is outside
in the outside I said an area say any
sound here goes to the side bus and then
here as you can see we can add a lot of
effects audio effects like amplify delay
everything just a lot of all the effects
you know not so we can for example have
different reverbs the smaller area you
can use a small river the big area you
can use a bigger reverb under your
Thunder the music is just a note it just
can you turn it on and it plays the
music pretty much you have reflection
probes it's a lot of things you can you
can use here particle systems and
different types of notes so
[Music]
you can see here that it's it's very
interesting if you have like this is the
original designs pixel art rice made
like 10 years old for this demo this is
the 3d the same artists actually made
the pixel art 10 years ago 1 2 3 D 10
years later he tried to him that he
signs as much as possible but it shows
like how much this technology has
improved over the years I guess so well
this concludes the presentation so if
there are any question we still have 10
minutes I think
[Applause]
[Music]
so are there any questions
hi so during your talk you mentioned
that the poly count doesn't matter so
what I'm wondering is if you profile
this so during the talk you mentioned
that you said the poly count doesn't
matter while you mirror on the models
I'm wondering if you've Pro felt this on
eye GPUs and if you compare that to high
low detail pass with normal baking who
can explain
GPUs keep improving maybe the artist
like 15 years ago were very careful
about not mean not adding to polygons I
mean when I say it doesn't matter is
that in general artists life seem to use
to using at least vertices as possible
but as technology keeps improving
you can still use more and more and more
on it it's not that it's course you can
always make too many vertices or too
many faces but for a while an artist
needs to make it look nice it really
doesn't matter so much like to know what
is if you make this main character and
if you made it like 40,000 polygons it's
fine is going to run everywhere it's not
going to be any problem like compress so
when you open it it's it will load
faster and with 125 you can also see
that the in the in the level the artist
he just didn't like model everything you
see from scratch here we used a lot of
objects so there's probably like 30
based objects that were already used
like a section was a put inside so it
like in a cylinder so there are no
astronaut that many not that many pieces
that make this level that you have just
seen there's a lot of reuse for that so
as most pieces are reusable and there
are not that many pieces being round in
general you just can go white which
ametrine that is fine it's not going to
matter much it's not like you're making
like something completely everything you
need professional 3d artist in general
they know that the more we can reuse
what they do
the faster they will make it they will
be more efficient because just doing
more and more and more is going to take
longer for them so in general for a
level
these normally you don't have that many
pieces or anything like that so it's
normal that you just can use higher
geometry and be fine with it if you're
making something like I don't know like
a squid where you can cover 10
kilometers distance of course you
probably need to use Elodie's just to
make like less geometry used on the
things away and occlusion and different
things but in general for what you see
clothes nowadays on a game it really
doesn't matter much how many polygons it
has because you have like
myrrh-streaming for a lot of these and
everything no it doesn't really matter
that much don't worry we still have
plenty more time for question out there
yeah it was about the Yusuke that you
mentioned about the Sanskrit if you have
to see an object like ten kilometers
away how do you deal with it in God like
I know that some techniques like
desolation role of detail is how does
God deal with it
version 3.1 which is coming now
still doesn't handle a lousy very well
because as I told you it touches one
year we have made a new 3d engine we're
going to put the engine to Vulcan next
year and all the missing options but
they generally the other with a lot is
that you make models with geometry if
you're going to make a ring that has a
very long the drawing distance usually
what you do is just you make versions
that have less this geometry and are
much simpler and when you import you set
the muscle OD so there are two two ways
of doing either you just make two
versions yourself or when you import you
set it right just decimate the model and
making useless geometry automatically
like automatic loads this is also very
common so one of the nice things from
the Matic loads is that when the game
loads at first is just those all the low
detail versions of the polygons and only
whatever is close it gets loaded like
that streamed as high detail so as you
leave the game a fixed amount of memory
it can use for models so when it runs
out pretty much because you're moving
and it needs to load a new high detail
one you use an earlier you approach
approach and it's going to like free the
high detail version of the older one so
you just now around the war and it's
going to what what is close it will load
the height version hide little versions
and what is Chi far away it will just
free the high detail version that's how
you're actually move around usually
games like in the case of the Assassin's
Creed the latest one the latest two ones
they use are really complex cooling
technique for like just showing very so
in cases of a missile that complex I
mean you probably need like a few
thousand million dollars to make a rim
like that you probably may want to write
a custom rendering pipeline that does
better like how what cooling or
something something enough for something
a regular team that is not one of the
dos and big studios that can make a game
like that
just using three minutes going to be far
far enough three more questions
you mentioned in the title about you to
alluded to making the next blockbuster
game using open source tools do you have
any major projects or game developments
that are under development using your
engine
if you check or we have a reel of games
that are being made we are going to make
a new one in a few weeks there are many
interesting projects made it's mostly
indie projects like you goddess-like
still pretty small in community compared
to the the they're very known engines
it's the fastest growing engine if you
check the lower game jam numbers it's
like duplicating every year we are not
likin the level of game maker or
construct like it's this small compare
like to unity not that small compared to
the Unreal but it's growing much faster
than any of the others
I think games that are like being made
I'm not really sure there are many nice
things being made if you check what the
community makes game published I don't
know I don't think so because the the
new 3d engine is like really new and
making a game that is very complex with
3d takes a long time so until we see the
kind of games made with the engine
probably a few years will have to happen
but people is making my things and is
growing very fast so I hope is going to
change in the in the coming years hi I'm
not a 3d model but I know a modeler in
the industry and he doesn't like to
recommend blend to new people of these
training up because the workflow is
completely different to other modelers
that are typically used in the industry
do you feel that's improving at all you
mean that the problem is have a non like
a recommend blender sorry sorry I didn't
catch I didn't quite understand the like
well just the way in which you use it
like even down to the keyboard shortcuts
and just the way that you use it is
completely different
I I don't use it myself so I'm not
familiar but I thought it was an
interesting point
okay okay you speak longer because the
speaker doesn't read so much here sorry
sorry when he's training new people he
doesn't like to recommend blender
because the workflow is so different
down to keyboard shortcuts and just the
way in which you use it compared to the
commercial modelers yeah
in general the thing is I think these
kind of things are in large part
generational we can you can check it
very well in there like a lot community
like most load users are young people or
people that has more will to try
something different
older people who has been working on the
industry for a longer time usually will
not want to switch technologies it's the
same with Linux it started like being
keeps making our operating systems on 30
years later it's like widespread and
used by everywhere I think this kind of
things are generational mostly at some
point when you grow so much others will
have to like give it a try and they will
have to adapt or die I guess at the
beginning it's always generational in my
opinion so I think blunder is perfectly
capable for this I think in Europe is
used quite a lot probably in in the
States not so much because they have
this idea that they need to hire a
company that sets up the computer with
my so they hire Alto this and all that
will set all their computer for them
with a rendering farm or everything just
for what they need this is a very more
more like an American big company
mentality but as soon as time passes I
think is going to change because this is
more generational than people realizing
that is good in my opinion thank you
yeah I just wanted to bring another
point of view to this remark I wanted to
bring another point of view to this
remark because I really think the
contrary industry should not dictate as
our standards are aware of workings and
one of the reasons that we are also
happy to and that's the way I use Godot
is trying to think if we can find other
workflows many artists you did precisely
because many artists use free software
graphics and free software imagery
precisely because you can intervene on
the workflow eventually we think the way
you organize things eventually do visual
transformation of the norm so I wish
that I agree the generation or I think
is really good answer that's that's a
way of saying it but we can change our
workflow it doesn't have to be us
adapting to the industry workflow and
this is what is killing your economy yes
I completely agree one thing I know is
that I have seen that impresses me so
much about open source is the way it
works generally it's like I will explain
it sure because I know we have very
little time but maybe on for this work
is really amazing usually when you have
an open source project it's the
contributors are mostly separated into
those who like create something which
are small and those who add something to
it and make it good you know so forgot
what happens the most is that we have a
really big community of contributors and
every feature is added is tested a lot
of and it criticizes a lot and it's
changed a lot we're a compatibility go
because someone comes up and says we can
this makes much much better if you do it
to a brush and make it again and it
happens a lot and what ends up happening
is that if you check the engine there
are a lot of workflows that are really
amazing really well thought if you
compare it to the commercial engines
they are like much worse than what the
lot is doing mainly because there are
this kind of internal competition which
is very healthy about who makes the best
version of every war flow or feature or
a lot of community complaints about
something
but maybe differently than if maybe
you're using I don't know unity or
unreal community we complain they don't
like something and that's it
England they will complain and they will
make a pull request and then other fleet
pretty sizable requests and hey whether
you'll also make it like this way I mean
keeps changing and improvement and we
have some discussions that may take
months to just decide how to make
something and indium everyone agrees
everyone always agrees Indian after
months of like arguing and the best way
of doing it that we have found out this
implementer that is really amazing so
when people trace out usually what
happened is that they are very surprised
about many of the workflows because they
they are very polished and very well
designed
maybe they Nick like to click for you
once you learn them but what you do is
once you do it like wow this is like
very well story and it's not like
there's someone who is a genius behind
that it's more like the wrestler very
well made community effort to discuss
everything and make it cool and make
sure it works the best as possible so I
think that I hope that kind of answers
or complements what you said with a
go-to engine do you have to do a lot of
testing for the multiple so you want to
it's a multi-platform engine you have to
do a lot of testing with different
drivers different vendors and hardware
and everything or is it pretty much if
you design it it'll run on Windows only
on Linux on a AMD or Nvidia or Intel for
this top drivers usually it's fine no
way the driver sorry I would both um
everywhere the problem we have now is
that we also been GL and OpenGL is
getting kind of duplicated by the
industry and the drivers are the
floating and they are very complex
drivers which can be dropping so we're
going to be moving to Volcom for the
next version because OpenGL is kind of
no longer viable us is very broken on
mobile it's kind of in usable so we had
to go back to OpenGL es2 from a while
because open G of 3 is just broken but
in general most testing is done by the
community I I have like I work
I have a lot of hard work until the
community tests and reports of art is
difficult to have it like perfect but
usually this is pretty efficient it just
works quickly that they report and we
and we take even they submit the pull
request with the pigs
hi I was wondering if you do any sort of
texture packing for your PPR resources
for example you can have a normal map
which is just two channels and resolve
the 3rd and pack the roughness and
mountainous into textures as well I'm
wondering if you do this and if you
could give some insight into what PPR
equations that you use and Godot right
here's a sinkhole you can use visual
shader with notes and you have a very
very complete default shader material
that has a lot of parameters it lets you
assign like every channel to everything
of the texture if you want so it's quite
easy to to to use it if you want just to
use the different channels in the
material you can use that you can use it
you can do it in many ways if you want
it is very flexible I was wondering how
much time and with how many people how
much time did you invest and with how
many people into making that demo I
can't hear you asked how much time the
people needed to create the demo this
demo was made in three weeks kind of if
you put all the things together yeah if
you're like very professional eyes you
can make this really quickly thank you
very much for your talk thanks everyone
[Music]
[Applause]